Hi, Mystery Recapped here. Today I am going
to explain an episode called “Good Boy”
from a horror anthology “Into the dark.”
Spoilers ahead! Watch out and take care!
Maggie Glenn is a reporter based in Los Angeles.
She is in her mid-thirties and has recently
broken up with her boyfriend of many years. At the
beginning of the movie, Maggie is in a restaurant,
patiently waiting for her date. She is nervous
because she has not been on a blind date since
college. The date goes well until she asks the man
about his thoughts on kids. He awkwardly says that
he hasn’t thought about it yet. He gets distant
after the question and barely talks to her.
Following the horrible date, Maggie returns home
and starts looking for someone else on the dating
site. She receives a message from a guy named Nick
but ignores it. The next day at work, she calls a
fertility clinic and makes an appointment.
Since she is about to turn forty, Maggie
wants to freeze her eggs as an extra measure to
ensure she will get pregnant in the future.
She meets doctor Linda who runs several tests
on her to see if her eggs are suitable for
preservation. Maggie knows that the process is
very expensive but she hopes to get promoted
at work very soon. However, her plan goes
in vain when her boss Don announces their
newspaper company is going digital. This would
mean that all the employees are getting laid off.
To keep them motivated, Don claims that they will
get to work from home and will still get paid if
they bring in traffic to the website. However, the
pay is very low and not definite. Maggie has been
working in the company for the past twelve years
and doesn’t know what she will do without the job.
She gets a call from the clinic, informing her
that she is eligible for the IVF program. She is
delighted but knows that without the promotion,
she will never be able to afford the procedure.
Her boss Don, who is also her good friend, senses
her anxiety and suggests she get an emotional
support dog. She takes it into consideration and
goes to a dog shelter. Although she had decided
to just take a look at the options, when she lays
her eyes on a tiny grey dog, she instantly knows
he has to come home with her. The shelter’s
employee reveals that the dog’s previous owner
went to jail and he was found by the police.
Maggie brings the dog home and buys him toys.
At night, she makes herself a Reuben sandwich and
keeps it on the kitchen counter. To her surprise,
the tiny dog somehow jumps on the counter and eats
her sandwich in seconds. Maggie laughs it off and
names the dog Reuben, like the sandwich. Starting
that day, she brings him everywhere she goes
and takes great care of the dog. helps her with
her anxiety like her boss had predicted. One day
while they are on a walk, Maggie notices a
vacancy announcement at a local coffee shop.
She starts working there as a barista for extra
money. At work, Maggie meets Annie Powell,
a girl who she used to babysit when she was in
high school. Seeing that Annie is already engaged
and has a huge social media following makes her
feel worse about her life than she already did.
The girls share their Instagram handles and decide
to meet again someday. When Maggie returns home
that day, a ball rolls towards her from under
the sofa. Thinking that Reuben wants to play,
she uses a rope toy to bring him outside. Reuben
from the other side pulls the rope so hard that
she barely manages to keep up.
To her horror, Reuben has also left
nasty scratches on the front door. She figures
he might be missing her and dismisses the matter.
That night before going to bed, she goes through
Annie’s instagram while complaining about her
life to the dog. She texts back a guy named Nick
from the dating app and arranges a date with him.
The next evening, she and Reuben go to Nick’s
mansion. At first, Maggie is impressed by the
size of his house but she soon finds out that it
doesn’t belong to him. Nick starts getting close
to her, making her uncomfortable. Reuben seems
to sense her anxiety. Maggie excuses herself
and goes to the washroom while Nick steps out of
the house to smoke. He hears rustling from a bush
and gets closer to inspect it. When
Maggie comes out looking for Reuben,
she finds him bloodied by the side of the road. To
her horror, Nick’s deformed dead body lies nearby.
A neighbor calls the police thinking that Nick
might have been hit by a vehicle. The next day,
Maggie takes the dog to the vet who runs some
tests on him and claims that he is perfectly fine.
The blood on his fur might have been splattered
on him from being too close when the accident
occurred. She also takes his blood as a standard
protocol for all dogs’ first time at the vet.
At home, Don calls to tell her that the story
she covered about Nick’s death is the first hit
of their website. Maggie jumps in excitement
when she is informed that one more hit story
will ensure she gets a bonus. That weekend,
Annie and Maggie go to a yoga class together.
All the other dogs in the class bark at Reuben
for no apparent reason. On returning home,
Bea sees Reuben for the first time and disapproves
of him being in her house. Maggie persuades her to
let her keep the dog, promising to keep him inside
a cage most of the time. Reuben senses that Bea is
making Maggie anxious and barks at her. Later, she
puts him in a cage to go to work. A while later,
Bea is in her bathroom when Reuben appears there
out of the blue. At work, Maggie meets a friendly
customer named Nate. He leaves her his number
on the back of the receipt. On returning home,
she sees that the dog has somehow escaped out
of the cage and scratched a hole in the window.
At the same time, she gets a call from Reuben’s
doctor who says his blood test results came out
abnormal so they want to draw his blood again.
After the call, Maggie enters Bea’s apartment and
finds her mauled dead body in the bathtub. A
horrified Maggie tries calling the police but
notices dog’s excreta on the floor and the broken
window. She puts two and two together and realizes
that Reuben has killed Bea. She soon registers no
one would believe that her tiny dog could kill.
If people find out, they would probably suspect
her of the murder. Still, Maggie isn’t mad at
her dog. Instead, she holds him tight and assures
him everything will be alright. Following that,
she cleans up the mess and wraps Bea’s body.
She drives it to the countryside and buries
her. After returning home, she buys Reuben an
even bigger cage to ensure he stays inside. She
totally ignores what happened and goes on with
her life normally. One day while sunbathing by
the side of the pool, she is approached by Bea’s
niece Elena who asks her about her aunt. Maggie
calmly tells her that she hasn’t seen her in a few
days. A police officer arrives to investigate the
disappearance. To Maggie’s surprise, the guy is
Nate, the customer who had given her his number.
That evening, they meet for a date at a
restaurant. The two seem to have a lot in common.
Maggie also finds out that having kids one day
is on Nate’s bucket list. They enjoy each other’s
company and decide to go out again sometime.
Maggie writes about Bea’s disappearance on the
website and gets more traffic than ever. Don texts
her saying she just confirmed her bonus. After
finding that out, she goes to the fertility clinic
once again to go forward with the IVF procedure.
She happily returns home that day but soon finds
out that her work “bonus” is only two hundred
dollars. She goes to Don’s office and confronts
him about the pay. They get into a huge argument
which ends when Don fires her from the job.
She brings her belongings to the car along with
Reuben when suddenly, the dog runs back up. Before
Maggie can go get him, she sees Don being attacked
by Reuben through the window. She quickly rushes
to Don’s room and sees his bloodied dead body.
Instead of freaking out, she calls Reuben a good
boy. Following that, she throws Don’s body off the
building to make it seem like a case of suicide.
She calmly brings Reuben home and cleans him up.
After Don’s death, Maggie gets promoted to his
position in the company. She now has a good job,
a loving boyfriend, and a backup plan if she
can’t have a baby. That evening Annie, Nate,
and her friends go to a bar to
celebrate Maggie’s promotion.
They also bring Reuben because Maggie is
too scared to leave him on his own.
One day at work, a policeman comes to see Maggie
to inquire about Nick’s hit and run case. He asks
her why she was at the location of the accident
to which she claims she was there to walk her
dog. The policeman suspects her story but has
no evidence to prove her wrong. In the meantime,
she continues visiting the fertility clinic. The
procedure causes bruises on her arms and legs as
a side effect. At night, Nate comes over to her
house with a dog cam as a gift. He has hardly
been able to spend time with her because she
always has to return home to the dog. Hence,
he believes that the dog cam will help her with
her anxiety when she is away from Reuben. Maggie
thanks him and sets up the cam near Reuben’s
cage. Following that, they walk to Nate’s house
while enjoying cups of icecreams. A man bumps
into them and walks away without apologizing.
Maggie shouts profanities at him, surprising
Nate. He calms her down and brings her to get
another cup of ice cream. In the following scene,
they are in Nate’s bed but Maggie is too worried
about Reuben to focus on him. She checks on him
through the camera but is still unsatisfied.
On returning home the next morning, she sees
some policemen arresting Elena, who had been
living in Bea’s apartment. They believe that
she is involved in her aunt’s disappearance.
Maggie quickly gets inside her apartment to
see Reuben has trashed it completely. Later,
she and Nate are hanging out by the pool
talking about Bea’s case. Nate is unsettled
by Maggie’s intrusiveness about the case. He
asks her regarding the bruises in her hands
suspecting that she is doing drugs. Maggie tells
him about the IVF procedure. She has the final
egg removal the following day, so Nate offers
to drive her to the clinic. During the process,
Maggie is given anesthetic drugs that make her
hallucinate. She dreams of the doctor confronting
her about all the murders. She tries to set free
but cannot because her hands are bound to the bed.
After the process, Nate drives her home since
she is too weak to do it on her own.
At night, he is working late, so Annie comes over
to keep her company. She tells Maggie that her
husband is forcing her to try for a baby. Back
in the police station, Nate’s superior tells him
about the prints that were found in three crime
scenes, including in Bea’s apartment. When he
finds out that Don’s crime scene also had the same
prints, he starts to suspect Maggie. He calls her
to tell her about the prints. Maggie freaks out
and asks Annie to cut the phone call. Annie tries
to reassure her that the prints just mean the
killer will be found quicker. Reuben mistakes
Annie for making Maggie anxious and attacks her.
He somehow grows into a beast and drags her into
the sofa. Maggie tries her best to save Annie but
is unsuccessful. After her death, she has no way
but to clean the house and get rid of the body.
She drives to the countryside and buries her dead
body. Not wanting to keep the dog anymore, she
drives away, leaving him by the side of the road.
In the meantime, Nate goes through footage from
Reuben’s dog cam and finds Maggie dragging Annie
through the door. When Maggie reaches home, he
confronts her about the murders and handcuffs her.
Just then, the transformed Reuben barges
in and attacks Nate, killing him at last.
A while later, policemen arrive at the
house and arrest Maggie for the murders.
In the last scene, we see Reuben in the dog
shelter yet again. The employee introduces him
to a man who presumably brings him home.
Subscribe for more videos like this,
turn on the notification, and leave a like to
help the channel out. Thanks for watching.